le revendre à ville est en passe d'être
le plus vite tempête
c'est pour ça qu'ils remontent tous vers
le nord j'en ai jamais vu autant il faut
voir les morceaux
enfin il pleut à peine il pleut des
cordes ici et je parle pas de plomberie
mais de l'océan toi aussi tu rentres
chez toi tu irais nulle part la tempête
approche à la vitesse grand v
je dois rester assis à regarder ça sans
rien [ __ ]
dirige droit sur l'aéroport il faut la
détruire avant qu'elle ne les pousse
accro star peut pas attendre que les
requins ou tombe à nouveau sur le coin
de la gueule
mais
on va balancer des bombes au coeur des
tornades c'est beaucoup trop dangereux
il va nous falloir amérique en plus
puissants le gâteau
il est temps de lever l'ancré en pâte
tout chez vous